we're staying in Montreal for our next
clip is it real or is it fake
it almost looks like it's some CGI
effect or it's out of a movie or
something I couldn't believe it what's
causing it
yes this clip is real and it was shot by
Michael bid in Montreal after a huge
rainstorm the force must have been huge
because first of all it's like
completely knocked off a manhole cover
when those things are heavy
but then it didn't stop there it
actually lifted up a car that's just
water that's what you drink that's what
you need to live and here it is pushing
up a car so what's going on here time to
consult our scientists for answers
in the half hour preceding this video
there'd been a torrential downpour of
rain in Montreal a Montreal isn't
perfectly flat stairs regions of high
and low and the storm drains can't cope
but you can imagine this is like a
u-bend system you've got water going in
one side and trying to push out the
other end and this is happening of one
of those low points when you have a lot
of water up here trying to get down
there there's a lot of force behind it
and all of a sudden it trembles
manhole-cover they said oh oh that's a
place we can relieve a lot of this
pressure a lot of this forest the
manhole isn't really held down enough
the water is strong enough to just push
up past that and had this huge geyser
effect
that's basically what happens when
there's too much water in your drain
system